I instantly regret the leather jackets I
look stupid I've made a choice just like
this hair is made of choice this one I'm
gonna fix this one I'm just gonna stick
with hello welcome to once-over
Wednesday is here on it's Grace and
today I'm gonna do um my favorites I did
this on my old channel I called it Daily
Grace is sexist and this time I'm just
gonna call it I like these things i l TT
uilt paper will think of a better name
this is all work in progress it's not
the end of the month it is the middle of
the month but I thought of hair haven't
done one of these videos on its grace
yet so here's just a bunch of [ __ ] that
I like because the Internet's for
sharing segue into why wearing this
leather jacket because I like it it's on
the list of things that I like can you
see it keep see it can you see it Keisha
Hannah came over here and hung out one
night and we were hanging outside and
then it got cold and then I gave her my
leather jacket because I'm a chivalrous
[ __ ] I was going to the camp
Takota premiere party I didn't have a
jacket to wear so I went to H&M thinking
they will always have one and they did
and so I bought this jacket from H&M and
I really really liked it it makes me
feel like a delicate motorcycle queen
I'm the person in the motorcycle gang
that doesn't own a motorcycle nor does
she want to ride on or near one but we
still hang out and get drunk and have a
great time and talk about all the
tattoos that I'll never get that's how
this jacket makes me feel next keeping
in mind with the theme of this jacket I
went to H&M because I'm going to New
York this week and I have a bunch of
very important meetings and so I got
some clothes and I realized that one
thing that I really love is fake leather
I got fake leather stuff because I can't
stop I got a skirt key C F G C F key
yeah this says business professional
that likes to kill shots and then I got
these and I don't know if I did the
right thing they're shorts and I don't
know I've just seen too much Kanye
West's in the media and I've been
influenced subconsciously or if I made a
good decision anyway they were super
cheap there were only $18 so I mean I've
spent more money on worse decisions in
my life so next oh I almost fell out my
chair got so excited about this next
thing sweatpants Casey a can you see it
can you see it I've seen pictures of
Justin Bieber I've seen pictures of a
lot of people wearing these drop crotch
pants and I thought to myself that's
[ __ ] stupid don't ever do that and
then I put them on my person and I
thought oh no we like them they're
comfortable and they give your cooter
breathing room umma and if you piss
yourself in a public situation you have
two extra seconds to figure it out
before it reaches the crotch area so
I've been wearing loose-fitting
sweatpants type pants like crazy eye
jeans
who needs them well some people do I
just want the low crotch low low low low
low next yes you see it you see it you
see this I think I've had this in a
favorites video before but it's just I
love it it's this Tarte bronzer and it's
called Park Avenue princess I definitely
have had this in the video before
because I remember distinctly hating
that name but it's the Tarte bronzer and
I've used so much of it that I can see
the bottom of it and so I decided to buy
another one but I didn't realize that I
bought the biggest [ __ ] one oh no
this one's called Amazon bronze
oh I lied I bought a different one oh my
god I haven't tried this yet but I just
like that it's so huge and makes me feel
so tiny and as a woman that's all I want
so I like Tarte bronzers they're very
nice and good for my next this [ __ ] so
yeah yeah you see it I have recently
done a video of st. Ives which is why
this is in this video and it's coming
out very soon and I'm super excited
about it they reached out to me about
wanting to work together on a campaign
for this new product which is there
fresh hydration lotion it's a spray
lotion which is actually really cool and
I like it and they let me you'll see
you'll see it's gonna be really exciting
what they let me basically make the most
ridiculous lotion commercial possible
for them on their channel which is just
like wonderfully stupid and then they
gave me so much lotion as a token of
their appreciation so much lotion has
been given to me so this is on my
favorites because I got so much of it
say knives more like Saint I don't know
it's st. that gives you a lot of free
stuff oh thanks
this you see AK yeah yeah this is a
Herschel backpack Herschel bags are
really popular right now and I got in on
the trend because I don't like to feel
left out of things nor do I have my own
opinions or original thoughts I just do
what others tell me I got this bag
because I needed a better computer bag
and this is a computer bag this is where
the computer goes in here and I love it
it's great it looks cool it makes me
feel sophisticated and like I do have
original thoughts so thank you for
creating a false illusion Herschel next
and last
[Music]
this see it you see it you see it this
has been on the list before but it's
back it's the Girl Scouts Thin Mints
coffee made coffee creamer dark and it's
delicious because who doesn't want
cookies in their coffee
Satan coffee made proudly supports Girl
Scouts and who doesn't
anyway this is fantastic well there you
go there is my list of [ __ ] I like or
what did I call this I like this stuff I
like these things I gotta create better
names for stuff I don't know did or
didn't yeah yeah yeah yeah